This is a solid chunk of sodium metal this stuff is number Eleven on the periodic table of elements
and it is extremely reactive
if it comes in contact with water
So a few months ago one of you left a comment asking me to flush a piece of sodium down a toilet
Which seems like a ridiculous request, but I have got cody from cody's lab to come out here with his infamous Mercury flushing toilet
So we can put that experiment to the test. This is the same toilet. I use for my flushing mercury experiment
I've cleaned out all the mercury and now I've got a spare toilet
So there's a pretty good use now if you take a quick look at sodium
It's a very Bendy very flexible metal I kind of think it's about the hardness of Beeswax
Sodium Metal is incredibly reactive it only has one electron in its outer shell
And so it's actually higher in the activity series and hydrogen now most people will store sodium in a container of oil because it prevents
An oxide layer from forming I just cut mine kind of in a jar
So you can see it's got that crusty coating
But if we take a knife, we can cut this open and for a brief second you can see that shiny metal
but within seconds you can see it's]oxidizing and forms that white scaly exterior coating a
Sodium metal does not like to be confined this piece is only the size a little bit bigger than a Marvel
But if we throw this into the toilet, and then drop a block of wood on top it creates enough pressure enough
Heat quickly the wood will get blasted back out 10 to 20 feet in the air. No problem. I
Think it like bounced around and it finally landed on top of it
It's like a good 30 30 feet from the flush zone if you feel this block would it's actually really slippery really slimy
So check this out we rigged up this contraption
It's just a long piece of PVC pipe so we can flush the toilet from about ten feet away
he's going to drop this into the toilet Bowl
We're going to let it fizz around for a bit, and then we're going to flush it and see what happens
there you go
i Can hear it crackling fizzing all right flush it okay Here we go
That's what you call explosive experience on the toilets
This is the biggest chunk of sodium I've ever thrown into water so a little bit nervous about this one. We're definitely
Flushing this from a distance, and I think we would actually have Cody throw a heading this time go for the smoosh
That reaction actually was pretty cool
This time we're gonna do the same thing we're going to flush it and see if we can make it go off during the flushing
Process, I'm wondering if we should go a little bit bigger just to take it to the next level
This is the grand finale. we've got a whole handful of sodium here like six chunks
I'm going to throw them in and at that exact moment
Cody is Gonna flush, and hopefully we'll get some kind of epic reaction ready for this
My goodness that's amazing check that out. It's still smoking. We got fired a little bit
Right in my face dang it that was epic. Oh my gosh guys. This is insane
Oh, we finally destroy the toilet that used to be a toilet now. It's a big mess that we need to clean up I
Honestly have to say I wasn't expecting that to go off like when you flushed it and nothing happened
I just sitting there thinking okay another fail, and then boom
crazy
So we broke a toilet I guess that's what happens when you flush a substantial amount of sodium down it
this is not something you want [to] try at home this is for demonstrational and
Educational purposes only you can see this is pretty dangerous stuff, and it is reacting with our skin right now
It's probably turning my forehead into a bar of soap, but we did this for you guys
Thanks for the request this is a ton of fun
I've never seen a toilet explode before anyway huge thanks to my friend cody for coming down here and making this possible for
Sacrificing this toilet on our behalf luckily. He's got a backup and we're going to do a video on his channel
Flushing liquid nitrogen down a toilet can the ceramic Withstand liquid nitrogen?
We're not sure so we're going to test that out go over to cody's channel and check them out give him a subscribe
He's got some epic content. Thanks for joining us for this experiment. We'll see you the next one. Talk to you then all
right let's clean up this mess
i got this toilet. It's got a lifetime warranty wonder if people. Take it back